the big headline from the long weekend
Donald Trump wants to end Dhaka what is
Dhaka and what would ending it do that's
a good place to start let's dig into it
Dhaka stands for deferred action for
childhood arrivals childhood arrivals
means people who were children when
their parents came to the United States
with them illegally the deferred action
being referred to is as you might
imagine deportation of those kids and
President Barack Obama remember him he
passed a program which shielded children
from deportation and it makes perfect
sense if you think about it if you're a
kid and you come to the US illegally
because your parents brought you you
grow up here you were not old enough to
decide for yourself what to do you were
not old enough to consider the legality
of what it was your parents were doing
you should not be punished and we should
not deport you particularly because the
average age of entry was six six years
old and you basically have a life in the
United States I moved to the United
States legally of course when I was five
and a half years old nearly six years
old and the idea of taking me at 26 for
example as are some of the dreamers the
so-called dreamers in this as referred
to under this program they take a 26
year old and say hey your parents came
here illegally so you're going back to
your home country which for many of
those individuals particularly if they
haven't been back it's not really their
home country anymore and we've learned
that Donald Trump is going to be ending
that program maybe after giving Congress
six months to propose a replacement Jeff
Sessions officially making the
announcement today yet another sign of
just Donald Trump's it's sort of just
like a scaredy cat right I mean why
can't he come out and make this
announcement himself sending Jeff
Sessions out there and the idea is if
Congress can propose a replacement that
actually goes through Congress not
something that President Obama just put
in place that will keep these dreamers
in the US without being deported then
Trump is I guess willing to consider
that but even among Republicans this
isn't a unanimously popular idea Paul
Ryan and a growing list of Republicans
and of course all Democrats they want
some form of this program to stay in
place and what they're using pad is
they're saying it was not done in a
constitutionally correct way you need to
go through Congress to do it and Jeff
Sessions kind of almost threw up a
little bit in my mouth when I heard him
say he said that this was actually the
repeal the the rescinding of daca daca
was an act of compassion and I don't
know how you could think that that's
some serious mental gymnastics there and
you know daca does affect 800,000 people
and within that group of young adults
obviously you're gonna have good and bad
you're gonna I'm successful and not
successful but some of those people you
know are in elite universities some
serve in the military I've seen
corporations in the whole country so
even from an economic standpoint how can
you rationalize this I think it's just a
clear move to the base well like much of
what Trump is proposing and we'll talk
about the trade with China stuff later
much of what Trump is proposing would
have economically disastrous
consequences which of course Trump has
not the brain power to understand a key
sort of practical question with this
repeal of daca is during this six-month
trial period of sorts until and we see
if we will get a replacement proposal
from Congress would people who receive
deferrals already do to daca be allowed
to renew that status if it comes up for
renewal during that six-month period
unclear maybe we will know some of these
elements by tomorrow it's also important
to realize that according to a report
from 538 regardless of what ultimately
happens with this six-month period or a
replacement or whatever trumps threats
alone so far when it comes to
undocumented immigration are already
having an impact an online survey was
done of daca recipients and it found
that about one out of five 20% of
respondents who were eligible already to
renew their status had not done so many
because they believe that if they do
that that information that they submit
will be used by the government to
identify and maybe find them for law
enforcement purposes and for other
reasons so this is already having an
impact no matter what ultimately happens
and it really shouldn't be too much of a
surprise to us because on the campaign
trail Trump said that you would go after
birthright citizenship with a local
anchor babies sure and so if he's
willing to target you know people not
only who have
control over their situation but where
they're born into children babies I mean
you can see how this would extend to
Dhaka is yeah if he's willing to go
after people born in the US he's willing
to go after five-year-olds who came to
the US illegally because their parents
brought them no doubt about it
daka's good policy but with Trump
there's always also a double standard in
the background or in the foreground as
it sometimes is I want to remind you
that Melania Trump first lady of the
United States Donald Trump's wife came
to the US and worked illegally she
worked in the US before she had legal
authorization to do so she has not been
punished the modeling companies that
hired her haven't been punished period
more than a year ago in August of 2016
Donald Trump said at a rally in North
Carolina Melania Trump will be holding a
press conference within a few weeks to
explain and address that issue that
never happened being married to Trump
that seems to be the real job that
Americans aren't willing to do at this
point and by the way I was as I was
reading all about the daca stuff over
the weekend Pat why does the alt-right
and why do white nationalists even like
Trump he's married to an immigrant who
was working in the US illegally his
daughter and son-in-law are Jewish and
he's indebted to Russia like what what
is appealing to a white nationalist
about I think he goes back to what Frank
mink said on the program last week which
is when Trump announced that he was
running for president he had this whole
thing about you know the Mexicans are
coming here illegally and you know some
I assume are good people when really
you're supposed to be flipping that
whole script around yeah that from the
get-go I think grabbed their attention
yeah I guess they haven't left them
since Slovenian models aren't exactly
the stereotype of the people Trump has
painted as the really bad ones that we
don't want in the country the video you
just finished watching was made possible
by you through the membership program
you can sign up for membership at david
pakman.com slash membership we are
viewer supported independent media you
can use the coupon code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount off of
your membership